Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. You Frenchmen, not a contender with having robbed us of everything we held dear, have also corrupted our character. The present condition of my country, and my powerlessness to change it, are additional reasons for me to leave a land where I am obliged by duty to praise men whom I ought by virtue to hate. When I arrive in my country, how am I to act and what am I to do? When the mother country has ceased to exist, a good citizen should die. If I had to destroy but one man in order to deliver my fellow countrymen, I would start at once. I would plunge the avenging dagger up to the hilt in the breast of the tyrant. teenage subject of suicide. And Napoleone Bonaparte is, of course, better known as Napoleon
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你们这些法国人，不仅夺走了我们珍视的一切，还败坏了我们的品格。我祖国的现状，以及我无力改变它的事实，是我离开这片土地的额外理由；在这里，我被迫履行职责去赞美那些我本应出于美德而憎恨的人。当我回到祖国时，我该如何行事，又该做些什么？当祖国已不复存在，一个好公民就应该去死。如果我只需消灭一个人就能拯救我的同胞，我会立刻动手。我会将复仇的匕首深深刺入暴君的胸膛。青少年自杀题材。而拿破仑·波拿巴，当然，更为人所知的名字是拿破仑。
Bonaparte. And we are looking at the origins of this titanic figure of French history. But the extraordinary thing is that, of course, he wasn't really French at all, was he? As that brilliant impression has conveyed to the listener. Hello, everybody, if you're still listening. Tom, I think that's one of the most extraordinary impressions you've ever done. Thank you. I think we'll just gloss over the accent completely because we could be talking for hours.
波拿巴。我们正在审视这位法国历史上泰坦般人物的起源。但令人惊奇的是，他其实根本算不上法国人，不是吗？正如刚才那段精彩的模仿向听众传达的那样。大家好，如果你们还在听的话。汤姆，我认为这是你做过的最精彩的模仿之一。谢谢。我想我们还是完全略过口音的问题吧，因为我们可能会聊上几个小时。
But it's conveying an important point, isn't it? It is. Well, he starts, you Frenchmen, you've robbed us of everything we held dear. You've corrupted our character. And he talks about my country and the country he's talking about in that beautiful Italian accent. Well, it's not Italian, is it? It's Corsican because the country he's talking about in that beautiful Italian accent. Well, it's not Italian, is it?
但这传达了一个重要的观点，不是吗？确实。好吧，他开头说，你们这些法国人，你们夺走了我们珍视的一切。你们败坏了我们的品格。他谈到了“我的国家”，而他用那种优美的意大利口音谈论的国家……好吧，那不是意大利语，对吧？那是科西嘉语，因为他用那种优美的意大利口音谈论的国家……好吧，那不是意大利语，对吧？
It's Corsican because the country is Corsica. Yeah. It's a Ligurian dialect, which I hope the listeners picked up on. Yeah. Genoese listeners. So Napoleon, as you say, a superhuman historical figure. I suppose eclipsed in the public mind now by the dictators of the 20th century, but for so long, he was the paradigmatic great man of history, wasn't he,
那是科西嘉语，因为那个国家是科西嘉。是的。那是一种利古里亚方言，我希望听众们听出来了。是的。热那亚的听众们。所以拿破仑，正如你所说，是一位超人般的历史人物。我想他在公众心目中现在已经被20世纪的独裁者们所掩盖，但在很长一段时间里，他是历史上典型的“伟人”，不是吗？
Napoleon? For Carlyle. The most titanic figure in 19th century history. Definitely. Even though he's basically off the scene by 1815. And sort of overshadows all those paintings, all those novels, Stendhal Stendhal's Le Rouge et le Noir, Tolstoy War and Peace. Napoleon is the cultural figure par excellence of the 19th century, I suppose. Which is why Ridley Scott is making a film about him. And of course, we're not in any way jumping on that bandwagon. We would never do that. I mean, I think we've been very conscious of the fact that we haven't really done much about Napoleon on the rest of history. We've done an episode on his venture to Egypt, and we've done some episodes on the Battle of Trafalgar, won by his great British counterpart, I suppose, Nelson.
拿破仑？对于卡莱尔来说。他是19世纪历史上最泰坦式的人物。绝对是。尽管他在1815年之后基本上就退出了舞台。他几乎掩盖了所有的画作、所有的小说，司汤达的《红与黑》，托尔斯泰的《战争与和平》。我想，拿破仑是19世纪卓越的文化符号。这就是为什么雷德利·斯科特要拍一部关于他的电影。当然，我们绝不是在蹭热度。我们绝不会那样做。我的意思是，我认为我们一直很清楚，我们在《历史余温》中并没有真正做过太多关于拿破仑的内容。我们做过一期关于他远征埃及的节目，也做过几期关于特拉法尔加海战的节目，那场战役是由他伟大的英国对手，我想是纳尔逊，赢得的。
But considering Napoleon's outsized influence on modern Western history, he's in a neglected area. So we're going to try and make amends today today and we're going to be looking specifically at his origins aren't we yeah so kind of young napoleon because eventually we'll make our way through all napoleon's life but we'll start this week by just looking at the young napoleon as we once looked at uh young churchill and i guess actually tom that reading that you started with which no doubt so many listeners really enjoyed i'm sure they did the important thing about that is the Corsican-ness. The Corsican-ness, I have to confess, like everybody, I kind of knew he was Corsican, but never really thought about how significant it was.
但考虑到拿破仑对现代西方历史的巨大影响，他是一个被忽视的领域。所以我们今天打算弥补一下，我们将专门审视他的起源，对吧？是的，也就是所谓的“年轻的拿破仑”，因为最终我们会走完拿破仑的一生，但本周我们将从审视年轻的拿破仑开始，就像我们曾经审视“年轻的丘吉尔”一样。而且，汤姆，你开头的那段朗读，毫无疑问很多听众非常喜欢，我相信他们会的，其中重要的一点是“科西嘉性”。关于这种“科西嘉性”，我必须承认，像其他人一样，我虽然知道他是科西嘉人，但从未真正思考过它有多么重要。
It had never occurred to me until doing the reading for these podcasts, how colossally important it is that he is not French. Well, there you see, Dominic, I have the advantage of you. I've been to Corsica and I've visited his family house in Ajaccio. Right. Yeah. And I've seen for myself the proud and rugged independence of Corsican people as manifested in the bullet holes that riddle any sign in French on that fair island. Would it be fair to say, Tom, Corsica, land of contrasts? It's not really a land of contrasts.
在为这些播客做阅读之前，我从未意识到他不是法国人这一点有多么巨大的重要性。好吧，你看，多米尼克，我比你有优势。我去过科西嘉，参观过他在阿雅克肖的故居。对。是的。我亲眼见证了科西嘉人民那种骄傲而粗犷的独立精神，这体现在那座美丽的岛屿上任何法语标志上布满的弹孔中。汤姆，说科西嘉是“对比之地”公平吗？它其实不是什么对比之地。
I mean, it's just one thing. It's just one faintly terrifying place. And the hostility to France is still very much there. I mean, so my friend, Jamie Muir, son of Frank Muir, the great comedian, he has a family house out there that Frank Muir got. So that's why I went and stayed there. And he was telling me the extraordinary fact that the French were planning to test their He has a family house out there that Frank Lear got, so that's why I went and stayed there. He was telling me the extraordinary fact that the French were planning to test their nuclear
我的意思是，它只有一种特质。它只是一个让人感到轻微恐惧的地方。而且对法国的敌意依然非常强烈。我的朋友杰米·缪尔，伟大喜剧演员弗兰克·缪尔的儿子，他在那里有一栋家族住宅，那是弗兰克·缪尔得到的。所以我才去那里住过。他告诉我一个惊人的事实，法国人在20世纪50年代计划在科西嘉测试他们的核武器。天哪。你可以理解为什么那里有一种某种……那可能不是那个词。不，那应该是个意大利词。不管在热那亚方言里叫什么。让我们先谈谈科西嘉，以便把拿破仑置于背景中。所以，18世纪的科西嘉。
program, their atom bombs, in the 1950s on Corsica. Oh my word. You can kind of understand why there's a certain freder. That's probably not the word. No, there'd be some Italian word. Whatever it is in Genoese dialect. Let's talk a bit about Corsica first to put Napoleon in context. So 18th century Corsica.
那是一个多山的岛屿，对吧？大岛，非常多山。贫穷但骄傲。贫穷但骄傲。非常好。粗犷、独立、贫穷且骄傲。这就是我们喜欢的岛屿风格。是的。
It's a mountainous island, isn't it? Big island, very mountainous. Poor, but proud. Poor, but proud. Very good. Rugged, independent, poor, and proud. That's how we like our islands. Yes.
而且它有点前封建主义，对吧？所以大多数人什么都不拥有，他们靠栗子和奶酪、橡子生活。是的，它属于热那亚共和国，但热那亚人实际上只驻扎在海岸，他们并不怎么深入内陆，而且正如你所说，大多数人说这种利古里亚方言。当拿破仑的父亲，也就是他的父亲卡洛·玛丽亚·波拿巴，在1746年出生时，它在技术上仍然属于热那亚，但科西嘉人已经开始起义了。
And it's kind of pre-feudal, isn't it? So most people don't own anything um they live on kind of chestnuts and cheese acorns yeah it's owned by the republic of genoa but the genoese only are really based on the coast and they don't really go into the interior much and most of the people as you said speak this kind of ligurianian dialect. And when Napoleon's father, so his father is called Carlo Maria Buonaparte, when he was born in 1746, it was still technically Genoese, but the Corsicans had started rising up
并进行反抗之类的，对吧？他们确实反抗了。而对于欧洲其他地区来说，这位伟大的桂冠诗人是詹姆斯·鲍斯威尔，塞缪尔·约翰逊的传记作者，他称他们为“勇敢而自由的人民”。他去了那里，此后无论他去哪里，当他去伦敦参加舞会之类的地方时，他总是穿着科西嘉服装，被称为“科西嘉的鲍斯威尔”。科西嘉人穿什么？一种骄傲、粗犷、独立且热爱复仇的服装。对。我可以想象某种贝雷帽。是的，腰带里插着一把手枪，也许。我想象裤子会非常大。但这就是那种氛围。非常强烈。对于18世纪那些热爱自由和解放的人来说，科西嘉似乎是一个他们可以沉迷的地方。这有点像杰里米·科尔宾领导下的工党支持者眼中的委内瑞拉。这是一个你将自己的幻想和政治理想投射进去的地方，我想。
and having rebellions and stuff, hadn't they? They have. And the guy who is the great laureate of this for the rest of Europe is James Boswell, the biographer of Samuel Johnson, who refers to them as a brave and free people. And he goes there and ever after he goes around, when he goes to balls and things in London, he's always wearing Corsican dress and he's known as Corsican Boswell. What do Corsicans wear? A proud and rugged and independent and vendetta
是的，它是古巴，不是吗？我想这是对应的比喻。有一个人是切·格瓦拉或菲德尔·卡斯特罗，他叫帕斯夸莱·保利。鲍斯威尔很爱他，他在法国撤离后最终被流放，去了伦敦，鲍斯威尔总是带他去参加聚会，以此炫耀。我以前从未意识到他作为拿破仑的榜样有多重要，因为他自称为“民族将军”。他梦想着建立这种新的、现代的科西嘉国家，拥有宪法、大学和各种公共机构。这非常具有启蒙色彩。这是民族主义和启蒙思想的结合，还有一点“国父”的暗示。这实际上非常具有拿破仑色彩，不是吗？那是
loving kind of costume. Right. I can imagine a beret of some kind. Yeah, a pistol slipped into a sash, perhaps. Extremely large trousers, I would imagine. But this is the vibe that's coming off. Very much. For lovers of freedom and liberty and all this kind of stuff in the 18th century, Corsica seems like a place that they can fixate on. It's kind of a bit like Venezuela for people in labor under Jeremy Corbyn. It's a place where you
在18世纪50年代。我的意思是，很有趣。不具有拿破仑色彩的是，帕斯夸莱后来成为了英国宪法的崇拜者，也就是18世纪所知的“混合宪法”。这提醒我们，在法国大革命之前，存在着一种“亲英热”，即对英国宪政模式的痴迷，当然，法国大革命和随后的拿破仑将非常反对这一点。所以科西嘉是那种意识形态竞争的驾驶舱，它推动了拿破仑战争期间的英法竞争。总之，卡洛·波拿巴是这个家伙帕斯夸莱·保利的超级粉丝。
project your fantasies and your political ideals onto, I think. Yeah, it's the Cuba, isn't it? I suppose is the parallel. And there's a guy who's the Che Guevara or the Fidel Castro, who's called Pasquale Paoli. Who Boswell loves and who he gets ultimately sent into exile after the French exit, goes to London and Boswell is always taking him off to parties and kind of showing off with him. I had never realized how much he is a model for Napoleon because he called himself the general of the nation. He had a dream of this kind of new, modern Corsican state with a constitution, with a university, with all kinds of public institutions. That's very enlightenment. It's that combination of nationalism and enlightenment thinking and the slight hint of the father of the nation. That's very Napoleonic, actually, isn't it? And that's
他在不同时期与他结盟。卡洛娶了一位非常美丽的继承人，名叫莱蒂齐娅·拉莫利诺，当时她才14岁。我认为这让你对那种骄傲而粗犷的浪漫方式有了一些了解。她是一位非常令人印象深刻的女性。拿破仑一直对她绝对忠诚，不是吗？是的。他总是说她是造就了他的人。绝对是。
in the 1750s. I mean, interesting. What isn't Napoleonic is that Pasquale comes to be a great admirer of the British constitution, the kind of the mixed constitution as it's known in the 18th century. And it's a reminder that before the French revolution, there was this kind of anglomanie, this obsession with the British example of constitutionalism, which of course, the French Revolution and then Napoleon will set themselves very much against. So Corsica is a kind of cockpit for that ideological rivalry, which powers the Anglo-French rivalry through the Napoleonic Wars. So anyway, Carlo, Carlo Buonaparte is a massive fan of this guy, Pasquale Paoli.
她生了数百个孩子，不是吗？大约有……他们有多少个？大约有10个或11个。他们最终都成了国王之类的。他们确实做到了，这在当时没人能预料到。所以他们在1764年末结婚，实际上。他们在1764年结婚。他们在1768年生下了第一个儿子约瑟夫。
And he sort of teams up with him at various points. Carlo marries this very beautiful heiress called Letizia Ramolino, who is 14 years old at the time. I think that gives you an indication of the proud and rugged approach to romance. She's a very impressive woman. And Napoleon always stays absolutely devoted to her, doesn't he? Yeah. He always says that she is the woman who made him what he was. Absolutely.
1768年是一个重要的年份，因为那一年热那亚人一直试图在科西嘉强加秩序。他们基本上放弃了。他们欠法国一大笔钱，于是他们对法国人说，其实，拿走科西嘉吧。我们受够了科西嘉。他们基本上放弃了。他们欠法国一大笔钱。他们对法国人说，其实，拿走科西嘉吧。我们受够了科西嘉。这真是个该死的麻烦。你们拿走科西嘉吧。所以法国人在1768年进驻了。帕斯夸莱·保利对此很不高兴，发出了武装号召。他基本上被赶走了，去了英国。他的支持者之一是卡洛，他到处奔走。
And she has hundreds of children, doesn't she? There's about, how many of them are there? There's about 10 of them or 11 of them. And they all end up kind of kings and whatever. They do, which no one could have predicted at the time. So they are married in the late 1764, actually. They're married in 1764. They have their first son, Joseph, in 1768.
正是在这种动荡之中，他的妻子，当时怀着第二个儿子，他们差点被洪水冲走，或者类似的事情，这非常像希腊神话故事。这非常科西嘉。1769年8月15日，她生下了这个孩子，他们给他取名为拿破仑（Napoleone）。这在科西嘉是一个并不罕见的名字。有时拼写为Nabuleone或Lapuleone。我认为Lapuleone对于19世纪初欧洲的统治者来说是一个糟糕的名字。专横的欧洲统治者。
And in 1768, that's an important year because that is the year that the Genoese have been trying to impose order on Corsica. They basically give up. They owe France loads of money, and they say to the French, actually, just have Corsica. We're sick of Corsica. They basically give up. They owe France loads of money. And they say to the French, actually, just have Corsica. We're sick of Corsica. It's a flipping pain. You have Corsica. So the French move in in 1768. Pasquale Paoli is not happy about this, issues a call to arms. He basically gets kicked out and goes off to England. And one of his supporters is Carlo, and he's sort of charging about hither and thither.
不，你不能那样做。但卡洛所做的非常重要的事情是，一旦法国人进来，他就适应了法国人，不是吗？他去弄了一个基本上是伪造的贵族头衔，这使他能够成为一名律师，当然，多米尼克，从长远来看，这也将使他的儿子们能够享受到只有贵族才能拥有的那种教育。确实，我刚才说11个孩子，我刚看了我的笔记，是13个孩子。哇。其中三个早夭，两个死于难产，所以确实很多。所以他向法国人献媚。
And it's in the middle of all this turmoil that his wife, who is pregnant with her second son, they almost get swept away by a torrent or something, some very Greek myth style story. It's very Corsican. And the 15th of August, 1769, she has this baby who they christen Napoleone. It was a not uncommon name in Corsica. Sometimes it was spelt Nabuleone or Lapuleone. I think Lapuleone is a terrible name for an early 19th century master of Europe. Domineering master of Europe.
而拿破仑，第二个儿子，他实际上是在这个被占领的科西嘉长大的。他不去上学吗，汤姆？我以为他去了。
No, you couldn't do that. But what Carlo does that is really important is once the French have come in he accommodates himself to the French doesn't he he goes off and gets basically a fake title a nobility title that allows him to become a lawyer but also of course Dominic in the long run will enable his sons to benefit from the kind of education that only the nobles can have exactly actually I said 11 children I've just looked at my notes it's 13 children wow Three of them died young, two in childbirth, so loads of them. So he sucks up to the French
好吧，他的母亲后来确实说她送他去了一所女子学校上课，拿破仑显然很想淡化这一点。但学校里有个故事说他们必须扮演罗马人和迦太基人。那不是后来在法国吗？还是在科西嘉？哦，是吗？
and Napoleone, the second son, he grows up in this occupied Corsica, effectively. He doesn't go to school, Tom? I thought he did.
我想那一定是在法国。哦，好吧。或者也许是。因为显然有个牧师……不，因为是约瑟夫描述的，说那是在他们在科西嘉的第一所学校。所以我不知道。我的意思是，显然有很多不同的故事在流传，取决于你读的是哪本传记，你会对不同的轶事给予不同的信任。所以他拒绝扮演迦太基人的角色，因为他想扮演
Well, his mother said later that she'd sent him to lessons at a girls' school and Napoleon, obviously, was keen to downplay this. But there's some story at school that they have to role play the Romans and the Carthaginians. Is that not later in France, though? Or is that in Corsica? Oh, was it?
罗马人的角色。哦，那一定是后来的投射，因为法国人后来开始将自己等同于罗马人，并将英国人等同于迦太基人。所以这可能不是真实的故事，但我不知道。我认为当你阅读各种叙述时，很明显有多个故事，其中许多具有某种神话色彩。所以我们所知道的是他在阿雅克肖长大。他是这个大家庭的一员。
I think it must be later in France. Oh, okay. Oh, maybe. Because apparently some priest... No, because it's Joseph who describes and says it was at their first school in Corsica. So I don't know. I mean, clearly there are lots of different different stories that are swirling around depending which biography you read you'll have different credence placed on different anecdotes so he refuses to sit under to play the carthaginian role because he wants to play the
这非常贫穷。他们并不是一个特别贫穷的家庭。他们有抱负。他们是一个有抱负的、向上流动的家庭。但总的来说，这是一种暴力、粗糙的成长环境，不是吗？他会看到法国机动部队焚烧乡村，屠杀叛军的羊群。他会看到叛军的尸体被挂在公共公路上，作为对那些反抗法国统治的人的警告。而他自己似乎……我的意思是，所有关于拿破仑小时候的叙述都说他非常具有攻击性、好争吵，而且他喜欢读书。汤姆，我认为这是他身上唯一有点吸引人的地方。是的，他是一个巨大的自学者，不是吗？绝对是。是的，而且非常痴迷于古代历史，他喜欢读关于罗马人和希腊人的书，总是读这些。所以从某种程度上说，他很像我。像你吗，汤姆？你在威尔特郡的荒地长大。
roman one oh there must be back projection there because the french will come to identify themselves with the romans and they will identify the the British with the Carthaginians. So probably not a true story, but I don't know. And I think it is clear when you read all the various accounts that there are multiple, multiple stories, many of which have kind of mythic qualities. So what we do know about him is he's growing up in Ajaccio. He's part of this huge family.
以及另一个贫穷、落后、农村社区。是的，贫穷但骄傲。是的。所以拿破仑，我们说他出生于1769年。1778年，当他九岁时，他的父亲卡洛决定他真的想让他去军事学院。所以军事学院是社会流动的明显引擎。
It's extremely poor. They're not a particularly poor family. They have aspirations. They're an aspirational kind of upwardly mobile family. But it is generally a violent, scratchy kind of upbringing, isn't it? he would have seen French mobile columns burning the countryside, slaughtering the flocks of rebels. He would have seen the corpses of rebels hung on the public highway as a warning to those who defied the imposition of French rule. And he himself seems to, I mean, the one thing that all the accounts of Napoleon as a little boy say is that he's extremely aggressive and quarrelsome and also that he liked reading tom i think that's the one thing that's kind of attractive about him yes he's a massive autodidact isn't he definitely he is yeah and very obsessed by ancient history he loves reading about the romans and the greeks always always reading about that so in a way very much like me is that like you tom you grew up in the Badlands of Wiltshire
你会参军并向上流动。是的。但也要学习法语，当时他几乎不会说法语。令人惊奇的是，当他离开去参加这所军事学院时，他随后离开了科西嘉八年。是的。所以1779年1月，他的父亲获得了让他去法国学院的许可，但他先去奥坦的一所学校学习法语，然后才能开始他的军事生涯。尽管他可能接受了这种相当密集的课程，但他从来没有真正学会说好法语。
and another poor, backward, rural community. Yeah, poor but proud. Yeah. So Napoleon, we said he was born in 1769. In 1778, when he is nine years old, his father Carlo decides he really wants him to go to a military academy. So the military academy is an obvious engine for
我读了亚当·扎莫伊斯基的著作，他的语法和用词仍然很差。他的口音一直是非常浓重的科西嘉口音。他的笔迹从未超越丑陋的潦草。这对我来说确实是一个惊喜，因为你所看到的对他的描绘总是让你想象他是一个法国人，而且他总是被描绘成一个法国人。但作为一个总是用这种浓重的科西嘉口音与法国人交谈的局外人的想法，这确实改变了你对他的看法，不是吗？
social mobility. You'll join the army and you'll move upwards. Yeah. But also to learn French, which at this point he barely speaks. And the amazing thing is that when he goes away to join this military academy, he's then away from Corsica for eight years. Yeah. So January 1779, his father has got permission for him to go to academy in France, but he starts off going to a school in Autun to learn French before he can embark on this military career. And despite the fact that he's presumably having this fairly intensive course, he never, ever learns to speak French particularly well.
因为强调他作为一个局外人这一点，在关于拿破仑的叙述中往往是缺失的。是的。好吧，我认为正如听众将从这一集中看到的那样，科西嘉人（这集中了他最早几年的记忆）与这八年的教育期（开始于他不得不参加某种法语补习班）之间的张力，是一个直到第二集结束才最终解决的斗争。不，因为在这一点上，他绝对认为自己是科西嘉人。他去了一所又一所军事学院，我的意思是，我们可以在这里花上几周时间去讲一所又一所军事学院，但它们都非常简朴，不是吗？它们几乎是按照
I read from Adam Zamoyski, his grammar and use of words remain poor. His accent is always a very strong Corsican accent. His handwriting never developed beyond an ugly scrawl. It's a real surprise to me, actually, because the depictions of him that you have are always, you can imagine him as a Frenchman, and he's always portrayed as a Frenchman. But the idea of him as an outsider who's actually always speaking to other Frenchmen in this very thick Corsican accent, it sort of changes your view of him, I think, a bit, doesn't it?
稍微修道院式的路线运行的，因为老师是修士和僧侣。是的，当我们称它们为军事学院时，这实际上有点误导，因为你以为他们只是在学习枪支之类的东西，但实际上他们不是。他们把所有时间都花在……他们学习古代历史。
Because the emphasis on him as an outsider is something that's often missing, I would say, from A Count's Anabolium. Yeah. Well, I think also that, as listeners will see from this episode, that tension between the Corsican, which focuses the memories of his earliest years, and then this eight-year period of education, which begins with him having to do a kind of crammer course in French. Yeah. This is a struggle that won't ultimately be resolved until the end of episode two. No, because at this point, he definitely identifies himself as a corsican he goes to these a succession of military academies i mean we could be all here for weeks going through military academy after military academy but they're all very austere aren't they they're all run on almost
是的。但也学习数学，因为他后来证明在数学方面非常出色，不是吗？他是。他是，说实话，这从来没有让我对他产生好感。但这很重要。
slightly monastic lines where you kind of get up literally because the teachers are friars and monks yeah and when we call them military academies, that's actually slightly misleading because you sort of think they're just studying guns and stuff, but actually they're not. They're spending all their time... They're studying ancient history.
因为精通数学会让你进入炮兵部队，是的，这就是拿破仑最终要去的地方。起初他想加入海军，这……相当了不起。他本可以站在某艘船的甲板上，而不是维尔纳夫面对纳尔逊。我的意思是，他的教育充满了这样的讽刺。所以安德鲁·罗伯逊在他的传记中有一个惊人的细节，在他的学校练习册的最后一页，在一长串英国帝国领地之后，他写道……是的，我看到了。那是拿破仑最终会去的圣赫勒拿岛。他读过的古典作家名单非常惊人。凯撒、西塞罗、苏埃托尼乌斯、塔西佗。
Yeah. But also maths, because he turns out to be brilliant at maths, doesn't he? He is. He is, which never endears people to me, actually, if I'm honest. But this is important
他读过伊拉斯谟。普鲁塔克是他最喜欢的。当然，普鲁塔克在18世纪是一个泰坦式的人物，因为普鲁塔克写了这种“伟大的生活”、塑造历史的伟大人物的思想。这显然进入了拿破仑的灵魂。但他也有一种浪漫色彩，因为他喜欢那种伪盖尔语诗人……你看到了吗，汤姆？我看到了，是的，当然每个人
because a mastery of maths leads you into the artillery yeah which is where napoleon will ultimately go to begin with he wants to join the navy which is yeah quite something could he have been on the deck of whatever it was instead of villeneuve facing nelson i mean his education is full of kind of ironies like that so andrew robertson his biography has the tremendous detail that on the very last pages of his school exercise book, following a long list of British imperial possessions, he noted, Yeah, I saw that. It's that little island of St. Helena that Napoleon will end up on. The list of classical authors that he read is extraordinary. Caesar, Cicero, Suetonius, Tacitus.
在18世纪都读过，完全是编造的，芬格尔，不是吗？是的，完全是编造的。所以他是一个……他是某种原始浪漫主义、民族主义和显然启蒙思想的混合体，因为他也读伏尔泰和卢梭以及所有这些东西。所以他从一所学院转到另一所。到1784年，他在巴黎军事学校。哦，多米尼克，我们一定不能忘记提到那场打雪仗，那太……不真实。不真实，但很重要，因为它极大地助长了神话。所以这是阿贝尔·冈斯关于拿破仑的伟大电影（黑白电影）中的关键场景之一。它持续了大约20分钟。根据
He read Erasmus. Plutarch was his great favourite. And Plutarch, of course, is a titanic figure in the 18th century because Plutarch writes this idea of great lives, great people who shape history. That clearly entered into Napoleon's soul. But there's a kind of romance to him as well because he loves the fake kind of Gaelic poet,ian did you see that tom i did yeah of course everyone
传说，拿破仑夺取了这场打雪仗的控制权。它持续了两个星期。他把他的打雪仗战士编成排和师，他们冲锋陷阵之类的。显然这是完全编造的，但这确实是一个有趣的例子，再次说明了拿破仑未来的职业生涯是如何被投射回他的教育中的，以及围绕他童年成长起来的神话。是的，我认为这绝对正确。在某些方面很难辨别真实的拿破仑，因为太多的资料是后来写的。正如你所说，是在编造他英雄的一面。我的意思是，我们所知道的关于他小时候的一件事，
everyone did in the 18th century completely made up fingal isn't it yes completely made up so he's um he's a he's a blend of kind of proto-romantic nationalistic and obviously enlightenment thinking because he's also reading new voltaires and Rousseau's and all these kinds of things. So he goes from one academy to the other. By 1784, he's at the École Militaire. Oh, Dominic, we mustn't forget to mention the snowball fight, which is so- Not true. Not true, but important because it feeds massively into the myth. So it's one of the key scenes in Abel Gance's great film about Napoleon, black and white film. And it kind of goes on for about 20 minutes. And according to
我的意思是，他知道什么？他是个十几岁的孩子，15、16岁左右。他的一位同时代人后来写道，他“不善交际，喜欢孤独，反复无常，傲慢，而且极其以自我为中心。大部分时间，他似乎生活在自己的世界里，踱来踱去，沉浸在思考中，手舞足蹈或自言自语。”这很像我十几岁的时候。真的吗？
the legend, Napoleon seizes control of this snowball fight. It goes on for two weeks. He ranges his snowball fighters into platoons and divisions and they storm hills and things like this. And obviously it's completely made up, but it is a kind of interesting example of the, again, of the way in which Napoleon's future career is back projected into his education and the kind of the mythology that grows up around his childhood. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. So much of, it's hard to discern the true Napoleon in some ways because so many of the sources are written later. And as you say, are kind of inventing this heroic part of him. I mean, the one thing we know about him as a boy,
我没有成为欧洲的独裁者。不，你没有。你成为了……你成为了什么？我选择了另一条路。我成了一名播客，多米尼克。英国领先的播客之一，汤姆。这就是我描述你的方式。
I mean, what does he know? He's a teenager, 15, 16 or so. One of his contemporaries said later that he was uncommunicative, fond of solitude, capricious, arrogant, and extremely self-centered. Much of the time, he appeared to be in a world of his own, pacing up and down, lost in thought, gesticulating or laughing to himself. That's very like me as a teenager. Really?
是的。不管怎样，他最大的事业是科西嘉。这就是我描述你的方式。不管怎样，他最大的事业是科西嘉。他痴迷于科西嘉，显然这在法国被激发出来了。他所有的传记作者都说他几乎肯定在学校里被其他男孩欺负，因为他的科西嘉口音，因为他个子很矮。他面色蜡黄。他的皮肤更黑。他法语说得不好。所有这些。他天生是个孤独者，是个读者，是个困难、尖刻的人。尖锐。我的意思是，我想一个处于那种情况的男孩，你有两个选择，不是吗？要么你完全抛弃你的科西嘉血统，彻底抹去所有不是法国人的感觉，
I didn't become dictator of Europe. No, you didn't. You became. What did you become? I took an alternative. I became a podcaster, Dominic. One of Britain's leading podcasters, Tom. That's how I describe you.
要么你强调你的科西嘉性。你拥抱那些让你被欺负的东西。他显然选择了第二个选项。是的，他确实。我的意思是，他很好。他是个好学生，不是吗？他做得很好。他通过了不同的学院。1785年，他参加了炮兵考试。有58名候选人，他排在第42位，这听起来很烂。但实际上，几乎所有其他候选人都比他多准备了几年。所以对于一个准备时间没那么长，甚至不是法国人的人来说，这是一个相当不错的结果。他被任命为少尉，进入了一个著名的团，拉费尔团，
Yeah. Worn off. Anyway, his big cause, though, is Corsica. He's how I describe you. Worn off, anyway. His big cause, though, is Corsica. He's obsessed with Corsica, and clearly this is brought out by being in France. All his biographers say he's almost certainly bullied
驻扎在瓦朗斯，在法国西南部中心地带。实际上，对于一个如此好辩和困难的人来说，他实际上相处得还不错。他是个伟大的读者。他非常严肃。他并没有注定要有一个辉煌的职业生涯，但只要他保持法国身份，他就能有一个体面的职业生涯，因为他仍然有可能被卷入科西嘉民族主义的世界。他的父亲去世了，而帕斯夸莱·保利，仍然在伦敦徘徊，与鲍斯威尔交谈，并制定科西嘉大学的计划。
at school by the other boys because of his Corsican accent, because he's quite short. He's sallow. His skin is darker. He doesn't speak good French. All of this stuff. He's a loner by nature and a reader and just a difficult kind of abrasive person. Spiky. I mean, I suppose a boy in that situation, you've got two options, haven't you? Either you jettison your Corsican heritage completely and you absolutely erase all sense of not being French,
刷着他巨大的胡子。正是。他仍然在那里，拿破仑崇拜他。他的一位传记作者说，他把保利变成了某种虚构的父亲形象。实际上，他留下的第一篇文章是《科西嘉史》。他一直在写科西嘉的历史、关于科西嘉的文章、以科西嘉为背景的哥特式小说，所有这些奇怪的东西。我的意思是，我认为对于任何一个痴迷于历史的青春期男孩来说，他并不是一个完全无法辨认的类型。非常喜怒无常，在智力上非常傲慢。
or you accentuate your Corsican-ness. You embrace what is making you bullied. And he obviously goes for the second option. Yes, he does. I mean, he's good. He's a good student, isn't he? He does well. He proceeds through the different academies. In 1785, he sits the exam for the artillery. There are 58 candidates and he comes 42nd, which sounds rubbish. But actually, almost all the other candidates had done years more preparation than him. So it's a pretty good result for somebody who hasn't done as much prep and isn't even French. And he's posted second lieutenant to a prestigious regiment, the regiment of La Faire,
汤姆，你是在描述你自己还是在描述……不，好吧，我只是觉得，你知道，任何听过这些的青春期男孩都会发现拿破仑的某些元素并非完全无法辨认。这只是说，我不认为他身上有什么特别的东西，在这一点上，能让他成为一个“命运之人”之类的。
which is stationed in Valence, kind of in the sort of southwest central France. And actually, for somebody who's so disputatious and difficult, he's actually got on pretty well. He's a great reader. He's very serious. He's not set for a glittering career, but he's set for a decent career as long as he stays French, because there's still a possibility of him being drawn, sucked into the world of Corsican nationalism. His father has died, and Pasquale Paoli, who's still hanging around in London talking to Boswell and drawing up plans for Corsican universities.
不，不，不。我同意你关于这一点的看法。如果他现在还在，他会在YouTube上发布严肃的对话。你知道，他会在TikTok上，所有这些东西。但你知道吗，汤姆？
Brushing his enormous moustaches. Exactly. He's still out there, and Napoleon worships him. One of his biographers says he turns Pauli into this sort of invented father figure. And actually his first essay that survives is a history of Corsica. He's always writing histories of Corsica, essays about Corsica, Gothic novels set in Corsica, all these kind of weird things. I mean, I think to anyone who's been a history-obsessed adolescent boy, he's not an entirely unrecognisable type. Very moody, very kind of intellectually arrogant.
非常喜怒无常，而且……他身上有青少年最糟糕的东西。我认为他是。想到他和我们详细做过的另一个伟大人物丘吉尔的区别。丘吉尔十几岁时很荒谬，到处说“我将拯救帝国”之类的。但丘吉尔很有趣，他很活泼。你可以想象他很有趣，而且非常讨人喜欢。所有拿破仑学校的同时代人都说他实际上很糟糕，他真的很令人讨厌，他非常……没有幽默感，你知道，他总是……或者与人打架，
Tom, are you describing yourself or are you describing... No, well, I just kind of, you know, anyone listening who has been an adolescent boy would find perhaps elements of Napoleon not entirely unrecognisable. And that is simply to say that I don't think there's anything particularly about him that perhaps elements of Napoleon not entirely unrecognizable. And that is simply to say that I don't think there's anything particularly about him at this point that marks him out as, you know, a man of destiny or anything.
只是一个困难的……为什么没人承认我的天才？是的，非常像那种十几岁的样子。他开始写哥特式小说。是的，当然他写了。我的意思是，当然。这正是你所期望的。他写了一本叫《埃塞克斯伯爵》的书。是的。一本关于安德鲁·罗伯茨的书。我忍不住想到了你的吸血鬼小说，汤姆，
No, no, no. I agree with you about that. If he was around now, he would be putting up earnest conversations on YouTube. You know, he'd be on TikTok, all that kind of stuff. But you know what, Tom?
因为安德鲁·罗伯茨引用了其中的一点。“伯爵夫人的手指陷入了张开的伤口中。她的手指滴着血。她尖叫着，遮住脸，但抬头一看什么也看不见。惊恐、颤抖、惊骇，被这些可怕的预感深深刺痛，伯爵夫人坐进了一辆马车，
Very moody and... He's all that's worst stuff. Very moody. He's all that's worst about teenagers. I think he is. Thinking about the difference in him and the other great character that we've done, his youth in great detail, which is Churchill. Churchill was ridiculous as a teenager going around saying, I will save the empire and all that sort of stuff. But Churchill was funny and he was a bullion. And you could imagine he was a great laugh and he was very likable all napoleon school contemporaries say of him he was actually awful he was really dislikable he was very had no sense of humor you know he's always yeah or having fights with people
到达了塔楼。”让那个年轻时从未写过哥特式情节剧的人先扔石头吧，多米尼克。然而，我确实认为我们有点不公平，因为正如我所说，他在数学方面也非常出色。那更糟。不，不是，因为这让他进入了炮兵团，这实际上是一件大事。所以我们不应该忽视他确实有前途，有一个相当辉煌的职业生涯在等着他。我的意思是，这并不算惊人，但相对于他最终可能做的事情，这相当令人印象深刻。同意。所以我们应该记录在案。所以他在那里。我们到了1780年代末。法国陷入了严重的财政困境，正如我们在做关于七年战争甚至美国革命的播客时讨论的那样。法国耗尽了财政，既是因为管理不善和巨大的结构性问题，也是因为一系列战争，这种与英国争夺海洋霸权、争夺美洲霸权的伟大竞争，等等。
and just a difficult why does no one recognize my genius yeah very much that kind of thing as a teenager he started writing Gothic novels. Yeah, of course he did. I mean, of course. That's exactly what you'd expect. He wrote a book called Le Comte d'Essex. Yeah. A book about Andrew Roberts. I couldn't help but think about your vampire novels, Tom,
而拿破仑，他坐在瓦朗斯的团里，实际上他伟大的梦想是写一部《科西嘉史》。这就是他正在做的事情。当法国政治主体被所有这些动荡搅得不得安宁时，路易十六召集了三级会议，法国的……愚蠢的比较，但法国相当于议会，试图解决其财政困境。拿破仑对此感到高兴，因为他认为法国宪法的自由化将给科西嘉更多的自治权。但也我认为他已经决定他是一个共和主义者了，不是吗？是的，他是。因为他一直在读卢梭，一直在读很多
because Andrew Roberts quotes a bit of it. The fingers of the countess sank into gaping wounds. Her fingers dripped with blood. She cried out, hid her face, but looking up could see nothing. Terrified, trembling, aghast, cut to the very quick by these terrible forebodings, the countess got into a carriage
启蒙运动的东西。你把他和YouTube或TikTok上的现代青少年进行比较，你知道，他吸收了所有这些东西，就像人们现在所做的那样，就像人们在历史上的任何时刻所做的那样，他吸收了当时所有时尚的思想。是的，你知道，他被所有这些东西充斥着……他一直在写关于自由之类的东西，但有趣的是，在这一点上，1789年，他仍然把法国人视为恶棍。所以他写信给在伦敦的帕斯夸莱·保利。他说，这是1789年。他说，我非常渴望写一部《科西嘉史》。在信中，他说：“我出生时，我们的祖国正在灭亡。我的眼睛睁开，看到的却是3万名法国人被呕吐到我们的海岸上，将自由的宝座淹没在血流之中。”非常像青少年的散文，但非常有趣的是，在这么晚的阶段，他仍然把法国人视为压迫者，把科西嘉视为他的祖国，把科西嘉视为他的未来。他确实这样认为，但与此同时，当1789年7月巴士底狱被攻占时，我的意思是，他仍然参与法国政治，不是吗？因为我认为他是他那一年唯一支持正在发生的事情的炮兵毕业生。当他许多炮兵的同时代人开始逃跑时，他实际上并没有逃跑。我的意思是，他确实回到了科西嘉，但他并没有流亡。
and arrived at the tower. Let he who has never written a gothic melodrama in his youth cast the first stone, Dominic. However, I do think we're being a little bit unfair though, because as I say, he's also tremendously good at maths. That's worse. No, it isn't, because it gets him his posting in the artillery regiment, and this is actually quite a big deal. So we shouldn't ignore the fact that he does have the prospect of a pretty
所以我认为在某种意义上，他能感受到这场萌芽中的革命的兴奋，并没有完全放弃它，而是把它看作一种……我的意思是，我想自由和博爱的思想是他可以应用于科西嘉的东西。所以我想拿破仑的问题是，你能解决这些矛盾吗？你能同时成为一个支持革命的法国人和一个科西嘉的民族主义者吗？这就是将决定他一生进程的巨大问题。多米尼克，休息后我们应该回到这个问题。我们会回来的。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
glittering career ahead of him. I mean, it's not kind of astounding, but relative to what he could have ended up doing, it's pretty impressive. Agreed. So we should put that on the record. So he's there. We get to the late 1780s. France has run into terrible financial trouble, as we've discussed when we did the podcast about the Seven Years' War and indeed about the American Revolution. France has exhausted its finances, both through mismanagement and massive structural problems, but through a succession of wars, this great competition with Britain for mastery of the oceans, for mastery of the Americas, and so on and so forth.
我们共同主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先观看现场门票，
And Napoleon, he's sitting around in his regiment in Valence, and actually his great dream is to write a history of Corsica. And that's what he's doing. While the French political body politic is being kind of roiled by all these ructions, Louis XVI recalls the Estates General, France's sort of stupid comparison, but France's equivalent of parliament, to try and sort out its financial woes. Napoleon is delighted at that because he thinks a liberalization of the French constitution will give more autonomy to Corsica. But also I think he has decided that he's a Republican already, hasn't he? Yes, he is. Because he's been reading Rousseau and he's been reading lots of
前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余温》，我们正在审视年轻的拿破仑。多米尼克，在前半部分，我们审视了他各种青少年男孩的态度、他偶尔的自怜感、他对各种浪漫事业的认同、他对革命日益增长的热情、他作为科西嘉人的意识，以及这是否会引导他走向公开的反法民族主义。所以，一个巨大的大锅，多米尼克，一个充满情感和思想的大锅。但当然，青少年男孩，他们经常感兴趣的另一件事是女孩。
enlightenment stuff. Your comparison with him and modern teenagers on youtube or tiktok you know he has imbibed as people do now as people do at any point in history he has imbibed all the fashionable ideas of the of the day yeah and you know he's he's sort of pumped up with all this stuff um he's very he's always writing these things about um liberty and stuff but interestingly he's still at this point 1789 he sees the French as the villains. So he writes to Pasquale Paoli, who's in London. And he says, this is 1789. And he says, I'm very keen to write a history of Corsica. And in his letter, he says, I was born as our fatherland was perishing. My eyes opened to the odious sight of 30,000 Frenchmen who had been
是的。那么，正如人们所说，他在那方面怎么样？在那方面。谢谢你，汤姆。说实话，他其实不是一个受女士欢迎的人。所以你可以想象，这些军事学院里的很多家伙都在偷偷溜出去进行约会之类的。拿破仑，每个人在谈到他时都说，当他们去参加沙龙之类的地方时，他看起来非常没有吸引力，但他有点瘦骨嶙峋、邋里邋遢，不是吗？他非常邋遢，他的头发看起来又细又长，垂下来。他橄榄色的皮肤，
vomited onto our shores, drowning the throne of liberty in rivers of blood. Very kind of teenage prose, but so interesting that at this late stage, he still sees the French as the oppressors and Corsica as his kind of motherland and Corsica as his future. He does, but at the same time, when the Bastille is stormed in July 1789, I mean, he's still engaged in French politics, isn't he? Because I think he's the only artillery graduate of his year who actually supports what's going on. And when lots of his contemporaries in the artillery start fleeing, he doesn't actually flee. I mean, he does go back to Corsica, but he's not going into exile.
倾泻在我们的海岸上，用血河淹没了自由的宝座。这确实是非常幼稚的文笔，但有趣的是，在如此晚的阶段，他仍然视法国人为压迫者，视科西嘉岛为他的祖国，视科西嘉岛为他的未来。他确实是这样想的，但与此同时，当1789年7月巴士底狱被攻占时，我的意思是，他仍然参与法国政治，不是吗？因为我认为他是他那一届炮兵毕业生中唯一真正支持正在发生的事情的人。当他许多炮兵同僚开始逃亡时，他并没有真正逃跑。我的意思是，他确实回到了科西嘉岛，但他并不是去流亡。
So I think there is a sense in which he can feel the excitement of this incipient revolution and isn't completely abandoning it, but is seeing it as a way... I mean, I suppose the idea of liberty and fraternity is something that he can apply to Corsica. And so the question, I suppose, for Napoleon is, can you square these circles? Can you be simultaneously a Frenchman who supports the revolution and a nationalist in Corsica? And this is the huge issue that will determine the course of his life in the long run. And we should return to that issue, Tom, after the break. We shall. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
所以我认为在某种意义上，他能感受到这场初期革命的兴奋，并没有完全放弃它，而是将其视为一种方式……我的意思是，我想自由和博爱的理念是他可以应用于科西嘉岛的东西。所以我想对于拿破仑来说，问题在于，你能解决这些矛盾吗？你能同时成为一个支持革命的法国人和一个科西嘉民族主义者吗？这就是从长远来看将决定他人生道路的巨大问题。汤姆，休息之后我们应该回到这个问题上。好的。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history we're looking at the young napoleon and dominic in the first half we were looking at his various kind of teenage boy attitudes his occasional feelings of self-pity, his identification with all kinds of romantic causes, his growing enthusiasm for the revolution, his sense of being a Corsican, and whether that might lead him into overt anti-French nationalism. So, a great cauldron, Dominic, a cauldron of emotions and thoughts. But of course, teenage boys, one other thing that very often they are interested in is girls.
请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com，那是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余谈》，我们正在研究年轻的拿破仑。多米尼克，在上半部分，我们研究了他各种青少年时期的态度，他偶尔的自怜感，他对各种浪漫事业的认同，他对比革命日益增长的热情，他作为科西嘉人的自我意识，以及这是否会引导他走向公开的反法民族主义。所以，多米尼克，这是一个巨大的大熔炉，充满了情感和思想。但当然，青少年男孩通常还对另一件事感兴趣，那就是女孩。
Yes. So what's going on down there, as it were? Down there. Thank you, Tom. He is not a man for the ladies, actually, it's fair to say. So you can well imagine that a lot of the blokes in these military academies are kind of sneaking out and having assignations and things like that napoleon everybody says about him when they do go to sort of salons and things like that he cuts a very unattractive figure but he's kind of scrawny and scruffy isn't he he's very scruffy his sort of hair is like lank and kind of hanging down. His olive skin,
是的。那么，在那方面发生了什么呢？在那方面。谢谢你，汤姆。公平地说，他其实并不是一个受女士欢迎的人。所以你可以想象，这些军事学院里的很多家伙都在偷偷溜出去进行约会之类的活动。每个人都说，当拿破仑去参加沙龙之类的地方时，他的形象非常不吸引人，他看起来又瘦又邋遢，不是吗？他非常邋遢，他的头发又直又垂。他那橄榄色的皮肤，
where they are paler, he has a thick accent. And his first encounter, which I know you greatly enjoyed reading about, is a very strange and unprepossessing one, isn't it? 1787, I think. Yeah. So he's in Paris. He goes to see a play and he comes out and he describes himself in kind of classic tones. My soul, agitated by the vigorous sentiments natural to it, made me bear the cold with indifference. But when my imagination cooled, I began to feel the rigors of the season and made for the arcades. And arcades is where prostitutes are hanging out. And he meets with a young girl and he's obviously wants to do what a chap wants to do with a prostitute, I guess. But also he feels inhibited
在他们肤色较浅的地方，他带着浓重的口音。而他的第一次邂逅——我知道你很喜欢读那段描写——是非常奇怪且不讨人喜欢的，不是吗？我想是1787年。是的。当时他在巴黎。他去看了一场戏，出来后他用一种经典的语调描述自己。我的灵魂，被其天性中充沛的情感所激荡，使我能泰然处之。但当我的想象力冷却下来，我开始感到季节的严酷，便走向拱廊。拱廊是妓女们出没的地方。他遇到了一位年轻女孩，我想他显然想做那个年纪的年轻人想对妓女做的事。但他同时也感到拘束，
about it, partly, I guess, because of nerves, but also because he has this whole Rousseau attitude, la nouvelle Eloise of high-minded. It's all about emotion and the mingling of souls and all this stuff. So there's a lot of kind of Rousseau-ish type conversation with this poor girl who clearly doesn't want all this kind of conversation. And yeah, it's all kind of weird. And he writes it up in a kind of slightly odd way. He does. He writes like an essay about it. And he admits that basically he's talking to her for ages, just wittering on about abstract nouns. And she's basically said, come on, let's crack on. She does. She says to him, listen, we could warm ourselves and you can satisfy your fancy. And he goes back.
部分原因我想是出于紧张，但也因为他有着卢梭式的态度，那种《新爱洛伊丝》般的高尚情操。一切都关乎情感、灵魂的交融等等。所以他与这个可怜的女孩进行了很多卢梭式的对话，而女孩显然并不想要这种对话。是的，这一切都很奇怪。他以一种略显古怪的方式写下了这段经历。确实。他写得就像一篇关于此事的散文。他承认自己基本上和她聊了很久，一直在喋喋不休地谈论抽象名词。而她基本上是在说，得了吧，咱们快点吧。她确实说了。她对他说，听着，我们可以暖和一下，你也可以满足你的兴致。然后他回去了。
And in this whole description that he writes, he doesn't describe at all what happens after they go back. So there's a kind of, as biographers say, there was always a kind of prudishness, priggishness, Puritanism to him. I think it's the kind of 18th century cult of the of the sentiment isn't it i suppose so yeah james boswell never had these kinds of problems no he didn't but i mean i imagine there is a kind of awkwardness a gaucheness that he dresses up in these fine fine sounding enlightenment tones but yeah again he's not the kind of commanding titanic figure oh no that's destiny who you might think at this point. He's still very kind of shy, very awkward, insecure, I guess you'd say.
在他写下的这段描述中，他完全没有写他们回去后发生了什么。所以，正如传记作者所说，他身上总有一种伪君子气、自命不凡和清教徒色彩。我想这是18世纪那种情感崇拜，不是吗？我想是吧。詹姆斯·博斯韦尔从来没有这些问题。不，他没有。但我的意思是，我想这是一种笨拙，一种他用这些听起来高雅的启蒙运动语调所掩饰的粗鲁。但同样，他并不是你此时可能认为的那种指挥若定的泰坦式人物。哦，不，那是命运。他仍然非常害羞、非常笨拙、非常缺乏安全感，我想你会这么说。
Yeah, which I mean, we can be lenient, Tom, given that he is an outsider. He's a teenager. You don't have to judge him too harshly for all those kinds of things. Anyway, back to the revolution. I mean, he doesn't know it's going to be the French Revolution, I guess. We're only the stormy, the Bastille. Lots of his fellow officers, as you say, they scram. They're horrified. Yeah, they're mutiny and stuff. Even at this early stage, it's so interesting that his first instinct is to go back to Corsica. And he returns to Ajaccio at
是的，我的意思是，汤姆，考虑到他是个局外人，我们可以宽容一些。他还是个十几岁的孩子。你不必对他所有这些行为评判得太严厉。总之，回到革命。我的意思是，我想他并不知道这将是法国大革命。我们只是处于风暴之中，巴士底狱。正如你所说，他的许多同僚都逃跑了。他们感到惊恐。是的，他们哗变什么的。即使在早期阶段，他最初的本能是回到科西嘉岛，这一点非常有趣。他在1789年9月底回到了阿雅克肖。
the end of September 1789. And he finds, and this will be a theme throughout the rest of this episode, he finds Corsica basically in total and utter chaos. Because French rule has never been entirely accepted by all the Corsicans, has it? And some of the Corsicans are sending, there's a man called, with the unfortunate name of Butafocco. Yes. I wondered whether you would be mentioning him. So Matteo Butafoco, he's the representative of the nobility, and he is sent off to France to say, can we have a bit more self-rule? Other people want greater integration into France. But meanwhile, I mean, that's just the sort of the surface political stuff.
他发现——这将是本集余下部分的一个主题——科西嘉岛基本上处于彻底的混乱之中。因为法国的统治从未被所有科西嘉人完全接受，不是吗？有些科西嘉人正在派遣，有一个人，名字很不吉利，叫布塔福科。是的。我还在想你会不会提到他。所以马泰奥·布塔福科，他是贵族代表，他被派往法国说，我们能多一点自治权吗？其他人则希望更深入地融入法国。但与此同时，我的意思是，那只是表面的政治事务。
And underneath it, there's all these different clans and factions kind of fighting for control of the island. His brother, Joseph, who is on Corsica, has helped set up a patriotic committee, which he's the secretary. Napoleon himself goes around handing out tricolor cockades. You see, which is fascinating, isn't it? Because that is, of course, revolutionary. He's not at this point an overt nationalist, and yet clearly he's doing it for nationalist reasons. Yeah. And I think it would be a mistake to kind of impose too much a sense that he has clear thoughts on this. Yeah, I think that's right.
而在其之下，有各种不同的氏族和派系在争夺岛屿的控制权。他在科西嘉岛的哥哥约瑟夫帮助建立了一个爱国委员会，他是秘书。拿破仑本人四处分发三色帽徽。你看，这很有趣，不是吗？因为那当然是革命性的。他此时并不是一个公开的民族主义者，但显然他这样做是出于民族主义的原因。是的。我认为如果强加一种他对此有清晰想法的观念，那将是一个错误。是的，我想那是对的。
I suspect that it's his kind of emotions that are leading him. I mean, a bit like when he's meeting with the prostitute and he's disguising confusion beneath the show of fine language. I imagine he's doing the same with this really. Absolutely right. That impulse is controlling him at this point. The other thing about France is that I think he defines France at different times in different ways. Sometimes he sees France as the- Colonial power.
我怀疑是他的那种情绪在引导他。我的意思是，有点像他与妓女见面时，用华丽的辞藻掩饰困惑。我想他在这里也是一样。完全正确。那种冲动在此时控制着他。关于法国的另一件事是，我认为他在不同时期以不同的方式定义法国。有时他将法国视为——殖民强权。
The colonial power that is oppressing Corsica. But other times he obviously thinks of France as almost like a universal idea. Well, this is the great thing, isn't it, of the revolution, is that the ideals of the revolution are framed as being universal and therefore applicable not just to metropolitan France, but to Corsica as well. So it's interesting that as he's giving out these tricolor cockades, the colours, the red, white, and blue of France. He is also still writing his Corsican history book, Tom, which he claims that the Corsicans are the heirs of the Romans. And he also writes this mad thing. He writes, this is a short story he wrote. He writes a short story about an old man in Corsica who it's revealed his mother, the old man's mother was raped and
那个压迫科西嘉岛的殖民强权。但有时他显然认为法国几乎是一种普遍的理念。嗯，这就是革命的伟大之处，不是吗？革命的理想被构建为普遍的，因此不仅适用于法国本土，也适用于科西嘉岛。所以有趣的是，当他分发这些三色帽徽——法国的红、白、蓝三色时，他同时也还在写他的科西嘉历史书，汤姆。他声称科西嘉人是罗马人的后裔。他还写了这件疯狂的事情。他写了一个短篇小说，关于科西嘉岛的一位老人，故事揭示了这位老人的母亲被法国士兵强奸并
murdered by French soldiers. And the old man in a sort of death wish sort of style scenario, takes revenge on every Frenchman he meets and boards a ship and kills everybody on the French ship, including the cabin boy. Yeah. We dragged their bodies to our altar and there burned them all. The new incense seemed to please the deity. God. Yeah.
杀害了。这位老人以一种求死的心态，向他遇到的每一个法国人复仇，他登上了一艘船，杀死了船上的每一个人，包括侍者。是的。我们把他们的尸体拖到我们的祭坛上，然后把他们全都烧了。新的香火似乎取悦了神灵。天哪。是的。
Which, of course, again again is simultaneously very you know corsican vendetta all that kind of stuff but is also looking forward to the terror yeah and the idea of blood and violence as being pleasing to you know the goddess of reason or whatever yeah so confusing times for a young lad the whole thing aboutorsica is so chaotic and anarchic. So by 1790, he's still there. They've sent a letter. He has actually composed a letter that ends up being read out
这当然又一次非常——你知道，科西嘉式的复仇等等——但也预示了恐怖统治。是的，那种认为鲜血和暴力能取悦理性女神之类的观念。是的，所以对于一个年轻人来说，这是混乱的时代。关于科西嘉岛的一切都如此混乱和无政府状态。所以到了1790年，他还在那里。他们寄出了一封信。他实际上起草了一封信，最终被读了出来，
in the French National Assembly, which is effectively asking for Corsica to be fully integrated into the French nation. Which is weird, isn't it? Because he's writing that at the same time as he's writing his,
在法国国民议会中，这实际上是要求科西嘉岛完全融入法兰西民族。这很奇怪，不是吗？因为他在写那封信的同时，也在写他的，
you know, genocidal fantasy about killing Frenchmen. As you said, it's so confused and chaotic. He gets his brother elected to the General Assembly in Corsica, and they're sort of having gang fights with other Corsicans. Then this guy, Pasquale Paoli, he makes a triumphant return to Corsica in the summer of 1790. Napoleon makes sure he's there in Ajaccio to welcome him. He's in the crowds. He and his brother Joseph and all their friends and some of the other brothers,
你知道，关于屠杀法国人的种族灭绝幻想。正如你所说，这太混乱了。他让他的哥哥当选为科西嘉岛国民议会议员，他们正与其他科西嘉人进行帮派斗殴。然后这个叫帕斯夸莱·保利的人，在1790年夏天凯旋回到了科西嘉岛。拿破仑确保他在阿雅克肖迎接他。他在人群中。他和他的哥哥约瑟夫以及他们所有的朋友，还有其他一些兄弟，
they're part of patriotic clubs in Ajaccio. They're giving speeches. He's kind of roistering around the streets, having fights. He's also engaging in class warfare, isn't he? Because he writes a letter at Butterfucko. Right. You did that with far too much relish, and I think that the listeners will see through you. No, not at all. Not at all. Butterfucko, of course, is the representative of the nobility. And by this point in 1790, the revolution in Paris is gaining speed. And so that element of class warfare is spreading to Corsica. And the Corsicans seem rarely to need any incentive to engage in fractious street fighting. But now they have a kind of additional motive. So it really is kind of chaos. It spends 1791, 1792, endlessly going back to France and back to Corsica.
他们是阿雅克肖爱国俱乐部的成员。他们在发表演讲。他在街上喧闹，打架。他也在进行阶级斗争，不是吗？因为他写了一封信给布塔福科。对。你带着太多的快感做了这件事，我想听众会看穿你的。不，一点也不。一点也不。布塔福科当然是贵族的代表。到了1790年的这个时候，巴黎的革命正在加速。所以那种阶级斗争的因素正在蔓延到科西嘉岛。科西嘉人似乎很少需要任何激励去参与派系街头斗殴。但现在他们有了一种额外的动机。所以这确实是一种混乱。他1791年、1792年都在不断地往返于法国和科西嘉岛之间。
Well, because he's still in the army, right? He's still in the army and he can't stay away for too long because basically he'll be a deserter. A deserter. And as the pressure rises within France, especially when the war breaks out with France's neighbours, he won't just be a deserter, he will be a traitor. So there's that beginning to hang over him. Yeah, because all the other officers have literally fled abroad and are starting to
嗯，因为他还在军队里，对吧？他还在军队里，他不能离开太久，因为基本上他会成为逃兵。逃兵。随着法国国内压力的增加，特别是在法国与邻国爆发战争时，他不仅会成为逃兵，还会成为叛徒。所以这开始笼罩着他。是的，因为所有其他军官都真的逃到了国外，并开始
make common cause with France's enemies in an attempt to restore the monarchy. Yeah. So June 1791, the key moments in the revolution. We'll be coming back to the French Revolution, hopefully the middle of next year, won't we, Tom? To mark the Paris Olympics, I think there'd be nothing more fun than doing a whole series about the worst excesses of the terror. So this key moment, the king, Louis XVI,
与法国的敌人结成同盟，试图恢复君主制。是的。所以1791年6月，革命的关键时刻。我们希望明年年中会回到法国大革命，不是吗，汤姆？为了纪念巴黎奥运会，我想没有什么比制作一系列关于恐怖统治最恶劣行径的节目更有趣的了。所以这个关键时刻，国王路易十六，
decides he's going to try and flee the country, get out of France, it's all gone wrong. And he is intercepted at Varennes, near the border with the Austrian Netherlands, now Belgium, and he is brought back. And that's a moment when the paranoia of the revolution, the sense of kind of incipient looming violence,
决定他要尝试逃离这个国家，离开法国，一切都搞砸了。他在靠近奥属尼德兰（现在的比利时）边境的瓦雷纳被拦截，并被带了回来。那一刻，革命的偏执，那种隐约逼近的暴力感，
really ratchets up. And at this point, the stakes are getting higher and higher. So a false move from Napoleon, if he allies himself with the wrong faction, things, of course, can completely spill out of control. He was no longer just a teenager playing at politics. could lose his life if if things don't work out and actually after multiple trips he's back in ajaxio in april 1792 and there are lots of murders going on there is fighting he ends up in a sort of massive brawl in the streets and pasquale paoli who's been
真的加剧了。在这一点上，赌注越来越高。所以拿破仑的一个错误举动，如果他与错误的派系结盟，事情当然会完全失控。他不再只是一个玩弄政治的少年。如果事情不顺利，他可能会失去生命。事实上，在多次往返后，他在1792年4月回到了阿雅克肖，那里发生了许多谋杀案，有战斗。他最终卷入了一场大规模的街头斗殴，而帕斯夸莱·保利，他到目前为止一直
very fond of him up to this point, because he's seen him as a fan, basically, starts to kind of wash his hands with the Bonapartes and thinks that whole family are much more trouble than they're worth. This is what happens, he says, when inexperienced little boys are placed in command of the National Guards. So at that point, about 1792, I would say, Napoleon's position in Corsica, where he had fancied himself as one of Pasquale Paolo's kind of nationalist coming men, is actually beginning to slip out of control. He's losing traction in Corsica is very unamused by Napoleon's activities and actually
非常喜欢他，因为他基本上把他看作一个粉丝，开始有点想甩掉波拿巴家族，认为这一家人带来的麻烦远比他们的价值大。他说，这就是当缺乏经验的小男孩被任命指挥国民警卫队时会发生的事情。所以在那一点上，大约1792年，我想说，拿破仑在科西嘉岛的地位——他曾自认为是帕斯夸莱·保利那种民族主义后起之秀——实际上开始失控。他在科西嘉岛失去了影响力，保利对拿破仑的活动非常不悦，实际上
writes to the war ministry in Paris saying, essentially, that he's a traitor, that he should be dismissed. This is very alarming for Napoleon. When he, in the summer of 1792, goes back to Paris, he has that kind of hanging over him, the worry about what people in the war ministry are going to be making of this. But fortunately, he arrives in Paris, goes to the war ministry, and discovers that it's absolute chaos there as well. And that if the letters arrive, certainly no one has read it. The letter says, that whole family, the family has no merit other than spying, treachery, vice, impudence, and prostitution, which is a harsh thing to say about somebody's family but as you say yeah the woman's just in chaos because france is suddenly at war
写信给巴黎的战争部，本质上说他是叛徒，应该被解职。这对拿破仑来说非常令人担忧。当他在1792年夏天回到巴黎时，他背负着这种压力，担心战争部的人会怎么看这件事。但幸运的是，他到达巴黎，去了战争部，发现那里也绝对是一片混乱。如果信件到了，肯定没人读过。信上说，那一家人，除了间谍、背叛、邪恶、厚颜无耻和卖淫之外，没有任何优点。这对某人的家庭来说是一句严厉的话，但正如你所说，是的，因为法国突然与邻国开战，整个国家陷入了混乱。
with its neighbors and he is actually on the 20th of june 1792 very french behaviors met up with a friend for lunch for a long lunch at a local brasserie and when they come out they see this huge crowd descending on the tuileries on the palace. This is the moment when the crowd, this mob, forces the king, who's basically now a prisoner under palace arrest, to put on the red cap of liberty. Napoleon sees this. It's really interesting because you said he was a Republican. He is a Republican, but he's also always an autocrat. He's a believer in strong, ruthless government, I think.
1792年6月20日，他表现得非常法国化，和一个朋友在当地的一家小酒馆吃了一顿漫长的午餐。当他们出来时，他们看到一大群人涌向杜伊勒里宫。这是人群——暴民——强迫国王（他基本上现在是宫廷软禁下的囚犯）戴上红色自由帽的时刻。拿破仑看到了这一点。这真的很有趣，因为你说他是共和党人。他是共和党人，但他也是一个独裁者。我认为他是一个强大、无情政府的信徒。
Well, he believes in order, doesn't he? He does believe in order because he says- Because he's a believer in strong, ruthless government, I think. Well, he believes in order, doesn't he? He does believe in order. Because he's a military man. So, I mean, his whole education has instilled that in him. And he says of the king, and it's so interesting that he says this in Italian, not in French. He says, Che coglioni! What a jerk.
嗯，他相信秩序，不是吗？他确实相信秩序，因为他说——因为他是一个强大、无情政府的信徒，我想。嗯，他相信秩序，不是吗？他确实相信秩序。因为他是一个军人。所以，我的意思是，他受到的全部教育都灌输了这一点。他谈到国王时说——而且他用意大利语而不是法语说这一点非常有趣——他说：“Che coglioni!”（真他妈蠢！）
What a fool to be so weak as to be forced by the mob to put on this kind of red cap. And then almost two months later, Napoleon, he's at his lodgings, and he hears the sound of the tocsin ringing. And he comes down to the street, and he sees this huge mob rampage down the street with the head of a man on a pike. And they're shouting, vive la nation, vive la nation. And actually, what has happened is the mob has attacked the Tuileries Palace. They have forced the king and his family to flee to the assembly for safety,
真是个傻瓜，竟然软弱到被暴民强迫戴上这种红帽子。然后大约两个月后，拿破仑在他住的地方，听到了警钟声。他来到街上，看到一大群暴民在街上横冲直撞，用长矛挑着一个人的头。他们高喊着“法兰西万岁，法兰西万岁”。事实上，发生的事情是暴民袭击了杜伊勒里宫。他们强迫国王及其家人逃往议会寻求安全，
and they have butchered all the defenders of the palace. And Napoleon, who despises the king, walks through the palace afterwards, the gardens, and the gardens are strewn with dead bodies of the Swiss guards and the nobles who were trying to defend the king. And there are still people there, as one of the historiographers says, finishing off the wounded and mutilating their bodies in obscene ways. And Napoleon is horrified by this. But what horrifies him is not so much the violence as the disorder, isn't it, Tom? This sort of anarchy, which he dreads.
他们屠杀了宫殿的所有守卫。拿破仑鄙视国王，事后走过宫殿花园，花园里散布着试图保卫国王的瑞士卫队和贵族的尸体。正如一位史学家所说，那里还有人在那里，了结伤者并以淫秽的方式毁坏他们的尸体。拿破仑对此感到震惊。但让他震惊的与其说是暴力，不如说是混乱，不是吗，汤姆？这种他所恐惧的无政府状态。
I saw even quite well-dressed women commit the most extreme indecencies on the bodies of the Swiss guard. So you can imagine what they're doing. And you're right that this in no way is an expression of sympathy for the king. And when the mob corner him and demand that he cries, vive la nation, he says, well, I did this very happily. Of course I did. But I think it's, as you say, it's contempt for the mob, the canaille, he despises it because you have to have order and discipline. So he's an authoritarian Jacobin. It's quite a recognizable type. He's very, very definitely a Robespierreist. I mean, he is definitely on the far left of the revolutionary movement, but at the same time, he's very, very authoritarian
我甚至看到衣着得体的妇女对瑞士卫队的尸体做出了最极端的猥亵行为。所以你可以想象他们在做什么。你说得对，这绝不是对国王的同情。当暴民围住他并要求他高喊“法兰西万岁”时，他说，嗯，我很高兴地做了。当然我做了。但我认为，正如你所说，这是对暴民（canaille）的蔑视，他鄙视它，因为你必须有秩序和纪律。所以他是一个威权主义的雅各宾派。这是一种非常可辨认的类型。他绝对是一个罗伯斯庇尔主义者。我的意思是，他绝对处于革命运动的极左翼，但同时，他非常、非常威权，
and thinks there needs to be discipline and structure and control. And it's about this point, would you say, so the Corsican-ness is beginning to, it never fades completely. He's still always Corsican, but he's no longer trumpeting it as he did before because he's perhaps found a new cause. Do you think that's? I think he has, yeah. I think he has in the revolution at this point.
认为需要纪律、结构和控制。就在这一点上，你会说，科西嘉属性开始——它从未完全消失。他仍然永远是科西嘉人，但他不再像以前那样大肆宣扬，因为他可能找到了一个新的事业。你觉得呢？我想他找到了，是的。我想他在此时的革命中找到了。
Yeah. Presumably, at the back of his mind, and this will become very evident in part two when we look at what happens over the next few years, he must be aware of the fact that the clearing away of so many aristocrats from the army has opened up a lot of space for a young man on the make like himself. Yeah. And that if only he can prove his value to the French Republic, you know, there is great scope for very, very rapid promotion of a kind that there simply wouldn't have been
是的。大概，在他的潜意识里——这一点在第二部分我们审视未来几年发生的事情时会变得非常明显——他一定意识到，军队中这么多贵族的清除，为像他这样有抱负的年轻人开辟了很大的空间。是的。如果他能向法兰西共和国证明他的价值，你知道，会有非常、非常快速晋升的巨大空间，这种晋升在10年前是根本不可能的。
10 years before. Well, that seems like the perfect point on which to bring this episode to a close, Tom. So we have this young man. What is he? 24, 25? Not even that. Who is driven, ambitious, very prickly, spiky. Pretty humorless.
嗯，这似乎是结束本集的完美节点，汤姆。所以我们有这个年轻人。他多大？24岁，25岁？甚至还没到。他充满干劲、雄心勃勃、非常敏感、尖锐。相当缺乏幽默感。
Very humorless. I mean, there's no trace of humor whatsoever. Spends his time writing these gothic vampire novels or whatever it is. He's writing his history of Corsica. Tom, the parallels are absolutely extraordinary, aren't they? Well. Man of destiny. If circumstances had been different, who knows where I might be.
非常缺乏幽默感。我的意思是，根本没有任何幽默的痕迹。他把时间花在写这些哥特式吸血鬼小说之类的东西上。他在写他的科西嘉历史。汤姆，这些相似之处绝对是非凡的，不是吗？嗯。命运之子。如果情况不同，谁知道我会在哪里。
Exactly. On an island in the Atlantic. I will say this. Sometimes I do tease you on this podcast, but you have a very lively sense of humour. I think it is fair to say. You're too kind, Dominic. As was evidenced by that excellent reading
确实。在大西洋的一个岛上。我会说这个。有时我确实在这个播客上逗你，但你确实有一种非常活跃的幽默感。我认为这样说是公平的。你太客气了，多米尼克。正如本集开头那段精彩的朗读所证明的那样，
at the beginning of the episode, which I think a lot of people will want to immediately go back and listen to again because they enjoyed it so much. Well, so we will have another reading in our next episode. You're spoiling us. Which will be coming out on Thursday.
我想很多人会想立刻回去再听一遍，因为他们太喜欢了。嗯，所以我们在下一集中会有另一段朗读。你真是把我们宠坏了。它将于周四播出。
But if you want to hear the next reading, which will be done in a different accent, so making a kind of intriguing biographical point, you could, if you wanted to join the Restless History Club,
但如果你想听下一段朗读，它将用不同的口音来完成，从而引出一个有趣的传记观点，如果你愿意加入“不安的历史俱乐部”，
you could hear it straight away. if not we will see you on thursday for the next installment of our special on young napoleon so we will see you then bye-bye au revoir i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
你可以马上听到。如果没有，我们周四见，届时将播出我们关于年轻拿破仑专题的下一部分。那么我们到时见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻固定节目，
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
评论，一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。